hey guys it is Friday once again which
means it's time to get you all caught up
on the game me things that met it this
week in the news that really shouldn't
surprise anybody who's ever played a
video game before Activision has
confirmed that a new call of duty game
is on its way this year it's official
2016 s call of duty will launch this
holiday and is in development at
infinity ward the creators of the super
popular modern warfare series we don't
know anything about the new call of duty
game except that Activision have
described it as innovative I don't
particularly want to do the research but
I'd put money on the fact that every
other card game has been called that too
so we really don't know anything at all
this will be infinity ward's first card
game after 2013's call of duty ghosts
since the franchise is on a three-year
development cycle between infinity
Treyarch and sledgehammer games earlier
this week Ubisoft revealed that an open
beta for the division is scheduled for
ps4 xbox one and pc the beta will go
live on febri 18th the xbox one and on
februari 1950s t and ps4 it only lasts
until the 21st so you'll want to get in
quick but fortunately you can preload it
on your console or PC from the 16th the
open beta will include all the content
from the closed beta as well as an
all-new story mission that Ubisoft are
yet to detail if you need a little more
incentive Ubisoft have said that
everyone who takes part in the beta will
get a special in-game reward for the
full game when it arrives on march eight
there's also a brand-new trailer out now
which features a number of the game's
enemy factions Microsoft have confirmed
that quantum break will come to PC the
same day it arrives on Xbox one for a
limited time you can also get yourself a
free copy of the pc version by
pre-ordering the digital version of
quantum break the xbox one the game
won't support cross-platform play but
you will be able to retain states across
the platform Remedy Entertainment also
revealed an Xbox one bundle for the game
and that the xbox one version will
include a free copy
of the developers earlier game Alan Wake
as well as its expansion and plz addams
activision also revealed that destiny
will be getting a new expansion this
year as well as the film sequel in 2017
we already had a pretty good inkling
that this one was going to happen but
activision has announced that this
year's expansion will be both large and
new yep it's right up there with the
word innovative what that does suggest
is that the upcoming expansion will be
more akin to the sides as you taken King
as opposed to the smaller duck below or
house of wolves DLC releases as for the
sequel Activision has merely referred to
it as a full game sequel with no further
info at the time this script was written
and finally whether you wanted it or not
to watch dogs too is coming next year
during an earnings call this week
Ubisoft revealed that a sequel to watch
dogs as well as other high-profile games
like for honor South Park the fractured
butthole and Tom Clancy's Ghost Recon
wobblin will be arriving over the next
financial year which ends in April 2017
the publisher also announced to their
plans to launch what they're calling a
new high potential triple a brand with
strong digital life services but your
guess as to what that could be is as
good as mine let me know down in that
comment box what you cared about this
week and which of all of these upcoming
games you're most excited for this week
on site I tell you about five awesome
original games arriving this year the
bullet floor show covers up on the
sexiest unromantic all characters in the
game and we review unravel that is
everything I want to tell you about this
week as always be sure to have yourself
a wonderful weekend and I will see you
again on Monday